شكرا لميسون اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام مره
جديده في متابعه ساعه بساعه ولحظه بلحظه
لكل تطورات الاحداث في السودان هدنه لا
هدنه لم يلتزم اي طرف في السودان بالهدنه
التي تم التوصل اليها بوقف اطلاق النار
لمده 24 ساعه القوه السياسيه السودانيه
حذرت من خطر كبير على الدوله اذا فشل وقف
اطلاق النار وطالبت الجيش والدعم السريع
بالالتزام بالهدنه وتغليب الحوار والحل
السلمي للازمه
يمكن تمت السيطره عليها تماما
نحن نسيطر الان على القياده العامه
بالكامل تسيطر على مطار الخرطوم الرئاسي
ومقانون العسكري ان هذا تمر بالنسبه
للمبادرات نحن نرحب بكل مبادره لكن الان
الماركه
مع قوات الدعم السريع احنا نفصل ما بينما
يقوم به محمد حمدان وشقيقي
ثلاثاء قال الجيش السوداني ان لديهم
مؤشرات قويه بتورط اطراف اقليميه ومحليه
في الاحداث الجاريه في السودان واضافت
القياده العامه للجيش السوداني انه سيتم
الافصاح عن هذه الاطراف في الوقت المناسب
وذكرت القياده العامه للجيش السوداني ان
عناصر قوات الدعم السريع هربوا من مطار
مروى وحاولوا القيام باعمال سلب ونهب
بالمدينه مشيره الى انه تم التعامل معهم
بحسم عبر القوات الجويه ما كبدهم خسائر
فادحه حيث تم التصدي للفرقه الخامسه
لمحاوله اقتحام فاشله غرب الابيض وكشف
الجيش السوداني ان الموقف العام مستقر عدم
مناوشات محدوده في محيط منطقه القياده
العامه والمطار
واعلن الجيش السوداني اعتقال قائد قوات
الدعم السريعه في قطاع مروي وبث مقطعا
مصورا يظهر لحظه اعتقاله
اللغه اللغه
[تصفيق]
هذا
الثنائي
سته
في السودان
الناس كلها
يعني اربع يوم ما نايمين كلهم الاطفال بس
خايف
هذا هو اظهرت صور اقمار اصطناعيه الاضرار
التي لحقت بالقواعد الجويه السودانيه
نتابع
[موسيقى]
تفويض المعارك القائمه بين قوات الدعم
السريع والقوات المسلحه عده سيناريوهات
على مستقبل السودان منها سيناريوهات قادمه
انفجار هائل وسط الخرطوم دخان اسود كثيف
يصنع مشهدا قاتما للسودان احتمالاته هي ان
يفوز البرهان في المعركه وتنشق جماعه
حميدتي ان يفوز احميدتي ويتبعثر الجيش
وتدخل البلاد حربا اهليه نزاع يستمر
لسنوات طوال بين لا غالب ولا مغلوب يصطلح
الطرفان ويقتسمان الصلاحيات وهو سيناريو
الذي يتمناه السودانيون اللهم اخمل الفتن
اللهم ارفع السودان اللهم
السودانيين اللهم انظف قلوبنا جميعا
الحسد من الحسد من الحقد
قد تحسم المعركه عسكريا في بعض المناطق في
السودان لكن الصراع قد يطول بسبب
التقسيمات القبليه والسياسيه لكلا الطرفين
المتنازعين هذا معناه اننا امام مرحله من
الصراع الطويل الامد للاسف الشديد سوف
تستمر الامور هي على هذا النحل فتره اطول
مما هو يعني يبدو السيناريو الذي يرجوه
السودانيون هو المصالحه يلتقي حميدتي
والبرهان ويتفقان على دمج قوه الدعم
السريع مع القوات المسلحه ليكون للسودان
جيش واحد يحفظ الامن ويلبي امنيات هذا
الطفل الصغير
شايفين الدمار
شايفين الدمار يا ناس
اقسم بالله دانت المبعوثه الامريكيه لدى
الامم المتحده ليندا توماس الهجوم على
قافله دبلوماسيه امريكيه وكتبت عبر حسابها
في تويتر ندين بشده الهجوم على قافله
دبلوماسيه امريكيه في السودان وجميع
الهجمات على الدبلوماسيين وعمال الاغاثه
بما في ذلك الاعتداءات على موظفي الامم
المتحده في الخرطوم واجزاء اخرى من
السودان
اصيب مدير مكتب الاتحاد الاوروبي
للمساعدات الانسانيه في السودان في
فرنسيين اصيب بالرصاص في العاصمه الخرطوم
وقالت صحيفه نيويورك تايم كان قد فقد مساء
الاحد الماضي مع اشتداد القتال بين القوات
المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع في الخرطوم
واضافت ان زملائه في بعثه الاتحاد
الاوروبي بحثوا عنه الى ان عثروا عليه
اليوم حيث قالوا ان اصاباته خطيره لكنها
لا تهدد حياته
معنى من الخرطوم الان مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي اهلا بك معنا سالم
الاوضاع لا تزال تشير الى انهيار الهدنه
تماما
نعم بكل تاكيد هذه الانباء التي لدينا وكل
التفاصيل التي شاهدناها في اللحظات
الماضيه كلها
تؤكد ان هذه الهدنه باتت حبرا على ورق ولم
ينفذ منها شيء خاصه بعد الشكاوى من
المواطنين من سقوط العشوائي للقذائف بشتى
انواعها على منازلهم ايضا كانت سببا في
موت العديد من الناس بطرق مروعه في
الشوارع او في البيوت ايضا الان وصلتنا
الانباء بسماع ايضا دوي هائل وعنيف بعد
عوده الاشتباكات في ام درمان ودعيها الا
المدفعيه والاسلحه الثقيله كل هذا الامر
ياتي تزامنا مع
الكثير من الاشتباكات في اماكن متفرقه من
الخرطوم وام درمان وبحري بعد اعلان هذه
الهدنه وبعد بدايه زمنها المحدد سمعت ايضا
الكثير من الناريه ايضا مضادات الطائرات
المدفعيات الثقيله
تهز ارجاء العاصمه اذا الهدنه ليست حقيقيه
وليست على الارض الان هل هناك وضوح في
الاسباب التي يعزوا اليها كل طرف انهيار
هذه الهدنه لانه كل طرف يحمل الاخر
المسؤوليه
نعم فعلا هو هذا ما يحدث طاهر بان كل طرفي
يحمل الاخر المسؤوليه فيما يتعلق بانهيار
هذه الهدنه ويقول انه هو من بدا بالقتال
وانا ادافع لكن بكل تاكيد الذي ينظر اليه
المواطن السوداني انه كان ينتظر هذه
الهدنه لتحقيق مسارات انسانيه منطقيه لاجل
تدارك ما يمكن تداركه من القطاعات مثل
القطاع الصحي وكذلك توفير الغذاء وايضا
توفير احتياجات المواطن الضروريه ايضا مثل
المياه وغيرها كل هذه الامور كانت ينتظرها
المواطن السوداني
باعتبارها من اهم القضايا العنا المطروحه
بالنسبه للمواطن هل هناك ايه حديث عن اي
حديث عن وسطات
لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه في خلال هذه الهدنه
التي ولو انهارت طيله ساعات الماضيه هل
هناك اي خط محلي اعلن عن شيء دخل على الخط
او لا او اقليمي او الدولي يمكن التعويل
عليه
هو ما
اذا نتابع واياكم هذه الصور الليليه
للاستمرار الاشتباكات في الخرطوم
والتي تحولت الى اطلاق نار متقطع كما هو
واضح على الشاشه رغم الهدنه التي انهارت
تماما منذ بدايتها
ولدت في مهدها عمليا ولم يكتب لها النجاح
حتى الساعه
يعني لا ندري اذا ما كانت هناك ايه جهود
يمكن الحديث عنها في الساعات المقبله
لانقاذها او لتمديدها او تجديدها ولكن ما
حصل حتى الان عدم الالتزام بها من قبل
الطرفين مع تحميل كل طرف المسؤوليه للطرف
الاخر يشيب الكثير يقول بانه لا اساس جديا
لهذه الهدنه كي يتم العمل بها اتابع معك
سالم ونحن نرى هذه الصور ونستمع الى القصف
بين حين واخر لاتحدث معك عن ابرز يعني ما
يشير اليه المراقبون العسكريون فيما يتعلق
بنقاط القوه ون الضعف عند كل طرف ما قد
يعني يقول الكثير للمشاهدين فيما يتعلق
بامكانيات
الغلبه في هذه المعركه
نعم هذه المعركه تحتمل زوايا مختلفه لكن
في ابرز الزوايا الجيش السوداني الان يركز
على مساله القوات الجويه وهي ميزه يتميز
بها الجيش السوداني ولا يمتلكها الدعم
السريع في كل القضايا حينما يتم حساب
المجمل من القوه والضعف نجد ان الجيش
السوداني متفوق وكل تاكيد فهو مؤسسه عريقه
وقديمه ولديه الخبره الكافيه في اداره
الحروب لكن ما يقيد حركه الجيش السوداني
في هذه العمليات ويجعل هناك صعوبه في
قدرته على حسم مثل هذه المعارك هو ان هذه
المعارك تدار في مدن الان مدن مليئه
بالمدنيين مليئه بالمواطنين في اماكن
مكتظه بالسكان فيها العديد من المرافق
الحيويه من مستشفيات وغيرها وهذا ما
يدفعني للحديث عن الشكاوى التي ترفع كل
حين في اغلاق المستشفيات المتكرره الان
يعني واستهداف حتى للمستشفيات نفسه يعني
هناك استهداف واضح للمستشفيات تكبر هذا
الحدث خلال اليوم والامس كذلك في
الاستهداف مثلا لمستشفى في ظل الذي جاءت
المناشدات للجهات المسؤوله بالتدخل العاجل
كيف يفسر ذلك كيف يفسر ذلك استهداف
المستشفيات يعني كيف يفسر من قبل هذا
الطرف او ذاك يعني هل هناك اتهامات من طرف
لاخر بانه يتخذ من المنشات الحيويه
والمدنيه والطبيه
دروعا بشريه
يعني من فيها من الناس هو المؤسف انه يعني
توثيق مثل هذه الاستهدافات
هي مسؤوليه الجهات الامنيه وليست مسؤوليه
ادارات المستشفيات او المواطنين حتى
المواطنين حينما نسالهم ونسال ادارات
المستشفياتهم نتواصل حتى مع المختصين بهذا
الشيء الصحي يؤكدون انهم لا يعرفون من
الذي استهدف فجاه ياتي تاتي المخلوقات من
كل الاتجاهات من كل مكان للمستشفى فلا
يعرف من الذي استهدف هذا المستشفى وبعد
ذلك ياتي النفي من كل الطرف على كل نحن
نركز في القضيه الانسانيه بانه يجب ايقاف
الاستهداف لهذه المستشفيات من الطرفين
ويكون هذا الامر معروفا يجب ايضا ان تكون
هنالك فتح لممرات امن الايصال المساعدات
المتعلقه بالنظام الصحي نفسه وهذه
المناشدات التي تطلقها لجنه الاطباء
السودان المركزيه وتؤكدها كذلك نقابه
اطباء السودان وكل المهتمين وحتى المنظمات
المتعلقه بالمجال الصحي بشكل عام تؤكد انه
يجب ان يكون هنالك فتح للممرات للوصول
الكوادر الطبيه الامدادات الطبيه وكما
ذكرت هذا صلبه تحضيرات التي اطلقتها منظمه
الصحه العالميه بالتحديد
سالم دعنا نستمع الى ابرزها قبل ان نعود
اليك ارجو ان تبقى معنا
لقد وثقنا ثلاثه هجمات على المنشات الصحيه
لكننا نعرف الكثير ونحن ندين بشده مهاجمه
المنشات الصحيه والتي اسفرت عن مقتل ثلاثه
اشخاص على الاقل واصابه اثنين لكن كما قلت
هذه ليست سوى اول مره تحققنا منها نشعر
بقلق عميق ازاء التقارير التي تتحدث عن
استيلاء القوات العسكريه على المنشات
الصحيه
سالم اذن يعني نعرفه بان واقع المستشفيات
بسبب ظروف السودان في السنوات الاخيره
خاصه
الواقع الطبي والاستشفائي يعني غير سليم
مئه بالمئه كما يجب ان يكون عليه فكيف هو
الحال
وهي تتعرض اي المستشفيات للقصف بغض النظر
عن الطرف الذي يستهدف هذه المستشفيات ما
الحلول التي يلجا اليها الاطباء او
الطواقم الطبيه في هذه المستشفيات او
اداره هذه المستشفيات هل من حلول عملياتيه
ام انه كله يبوء بالفشل والمدينه كلها تحت
القصف
لا توجد حلول للاسف طاهر الحل الوحيد الذي
تلجا اليه ادارات المستشفيات هو اغلاق
المستشفى واعلان هذا المستشفى انه مغلق لا
يستطيع اسم حتى الحالات الحرجه والطوارئ
احيانا يكون هناك تصرف اخر بانه تغلق جزء
من المستشفى وهو المتعلق بالحالات البارده
والعيادات ويتم استقبالها الحالات الطارئه
فقط توجد مستشفى
فهي تستقبل الطوارئ فقط ويوجد مستشفيات
اغلقت بالكامل الاغلاق الكامل لان هذه
المستشفيات حينما تحدثنا مع اداراتها
وتحدثنا حتى مع الاطباء في اكثر من مستشفى
الشكاوي تاتي بانهم لديهم شلح في الامداد
بالنسبه للطاقه اولا للكهرباء يوجد شحف
الوقود كذلك لانهم احيانا حينما تنقطع
ينقطع التيار الكهربائي هناك مستشفيات
فيها مولدات هذه المولدات تحتاج الى وقود
هناك الوقود هناك شحف الامداد المائي كذلك
هناك شيء في الموارد المتعلقه بالامدادات
الطبيه باشكالها خاصه انه تم استهلا كبير
من المخزون الموجود في المستشفيات بعد
حالات الاصابات التي تتوارد على هذه
المستشفيات ايضا هناك شحف الموارد البشريه
نفسها بالنسبه للكوادر الطبيه في وصولهم
الى المستشفى مع هذا الاغلاق للطرقات وعدم
القدره على الحركه كل هذه العوامل تجعل من
الصعوبه ان يتصرف المستشفى على الامكانيات
التي كانت اصلا هي هشه في الفتره الواحده
ولكن للاسف حتى الكثير من
المنظمات
والبرامج العالميه التي كانت تعمل في داخل
السودان اضطرت الى ان توقف عملها او ان
تحد منه لا اعرف اذا كان يمكننا ان نحصر
اذا ما كان هناك من لا يزال يعمل حتى
الساعه في هذا الاطار
نعم هذه المستشفيات الان هي محتاجه لتدخل
عادل لكي يدركوا
النظام الصحي بالسودان من الانهيار الكامل
يمكن تدارك هذا الامر بمجموعه من العوامل
التي ذكرها المختصون في هذا الشان وذكرتها
يعني الكثير من
المنظمات وكذلك الجهات المسؤوله عن هذا
النظام الصحي وعن المؤسسات الصحيه تحدثوا
على انه يجب فورا ان يتم حل لعلاج مشكله
المياه وهذا ما تكفلت به ولايه الخرطوم
اليوم في اجتماعها انه يجب ان تحلق ذلك
مشكله امداد الكهرباء لهذه المستشفيات
توفير الامن لهذه المستشفيات والمنشات
كذلك وعدم استهدافها ايضا
توفير ممرات امنه لوصول الكوارث الطبيه
لوصول كذلك المصابين والجرحى بسهوله لاجل
علاجهم والعنايه بهم وتوفير كذلك الامداد
الطبي من الامدادات الطبيه كل هذه العوامل
تجعل هذه مهمه
مهمه جدا
لتوفير الوضع الانساني المنطقي في القطاع
الصحي على الاقل
نستمع على صوت الطبيعي
اذا استمرار سماع الانفجارات واصوات
الاسلحه الثقيله في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم رغم الهدنه التي انهارت في ساعتها
الاولى
ونرى بين حين واخر وميض الرشاقات من مكان
الى اخر واصوات القذائف والاسلحه الثقيله
تسمع
يعني بشكل واضح جدا ونحن نتحدث الى ضيوفنا
ومراسلينا مع رؤيتنا لهذه الصور الليليه
من العاصمه الخرطومه اذن صلب ما كان يتحدث
فيه سالم قبل قليل سنعود بعد قليل لنتابع
معه ولكن اهم ما كان يتحدث عنه استهداف
يعني المستشفيات وهو جزء مما يتحدث عنه
ايضا مسؤولو المساعدات بالامم المتحده
مسؤول المساعدات بالامم المتحده قال ان
استهداف الموظفي المساعدات الاراث المنشات
الخاصه بعمليات الاغاثه في السودان لا
يزال مستمرا واضاف في تغريده على تويتر ان
الامم المتحده تتلقى تقارير عن تعرض موظفي
الاغاثه لهجمات واعتداءات كل هذا مباشره
قادمه الكرام نستمع الى اصوات القصف
[موسيقى]
في السياقه حذر الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر من ان
النظام الصحيه في السودان معرض لخطر
الانهيار مع استمرار المواجهات المسلحه
بين الجيش والدعم السريع واشار بيان
المنظمه الدوليه الى صعوبه تقديم الخدمات
الانسانيه في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
وما حولها
لا يتسع المكان هنا مستشفيات تكاد تفيض
بالمرضى وان فاضت فلا مستلزمات فيها ربما
ولا حتى اكسجين
[موسيقى]
كفايات تحت القصف قصف بالتوقيت الحرج لم
يتمكن مرضى الكلى من اتمام جلسه غسل طارئه
لكن ما ترى ايضا لم يكن في الحسبان
ملاذ غير امن بعد قصف العديد من
المستشفيات وتوقف بعضها عن الخدمه هذا
مستشفى ابن سينا لا شيء غير النار تعرض
للدمار بعد سقوط قذائف عشوائيه عليه
وهذا مشفى اخر سمي باسم الشعب ولم يسلم من
قضاء في العسكر تدمر بالكامل يعتبر من
اكبر مستشفيات الخرطوم واكثرها حيويه
ثمه مراكز طبيه عده لكنها تعاني من نقص
المستلزمات والكوادر ايضا امر اثار قلقا
دوريا فضلا عن قلق السودانيين راح نشهد
اكيد انقطاع مش بس بمواد طبيه ولكن عدم
تسيير المرافق العامه راح يكون للاسف
الشيء اللي راح نواجهه
قريبا وهذا الشيء ما انه ابدا ايجابي
بالعكس لازم نتدخل بسرعه لما تتفاقم
الاوضاع اكثر واكثر
دعوات حقوقيه لوقف اطلاق النار لفتح
مسارات امنه لنقل المساعدات الانسانيه
للمدنيين وان تحققت لفتره فثمت تحولات
عسكريه بين حين واخر قد تجعل الحاله اكثر
ضبابيه
غذاء السالم العربيه
معنى من الخرطوم الان دكتور علي بشير نائب
رئيس نقابه الاطباء في السودان اهلا بك
معنا دكتور
نريد منك لو سمحت ان تطلعنا على حقيقه
الوضع الطبي والاستشفاء الان في السودان
مع استمرار الاشتباكات والحاله السلبيه
جدا التي تصلنا كمعلومات عن هذا الوضع
شكرا على الاستضافه الرحمه والمغفره
للشهداء ضحايا هذا الاقتتال العبسي وشفاء
العاجل للجرحى ونسال الله ان يجنب بلادنا
الفتن حقيقه الوضع الانساني وضع كارهي
والنظام الصحي الان يمكننا ان نقول انه
بنهار تماما يظل تعرض عدد من المستشفيات
للقصف المباشر وخروجها عن الخدمه
واخرها مستشفى فضيل الذي تعرض
بالاسلحه الثقيله مما ادى الى ثقبه في
القائد المركزي وصهاري المياه الرئيسيه
والمخصصه لمرضى غسيل الكلى كما ان هنالك
عدد كبير من المستشفيات محدد بالخروج عن
الخدمه نتيجه لشح
الوقود
اللازم لتشغيل المولدات الخاصه معك الى
هذه التفاصيل بس سؤال لو سمحت دكتور ساعود
معك الى هذه التفاصيل بس اسالك حتى لو لم
تريد ان تحدد طرفا انا لا اطلب منك ذلك
ولكن هل تتمكنون انتم من معرفه الطرف الذي
يستهدفكم كمستشفيات
حتى الان وهو
الاشتباك الذي يتم حول المستشفيات يتم من
قبل الطرفين
وبالتالي يصعب تحديد من هو الطرف الذي
اطلق هذه الرصاص ولكن هل هو استهداف مباشر
او انه يصيب المستشفيات لانه متبادل
يصيبني
فقط وليس هناك تعمد يعني لانه احيانا يكون
في مثلا اتهامات بالطرف الاخر بالاخذ
الناس والمستشفى يعني من في المستشفيات
دروعا بشريه فيقصفها والى ما هنالك انتم
ضحايا الان لهذا التبادل فقط وليس هناك
استهداف متعمد من اي طرف
نعم تماما تماما الان بخصوص الوضع في
المستشفيات كنت تتحدث عن يعني استهداف
يعني يطيح في كل مقومات هذه المستشفيات
وليس يعني فقط بالوقود والمعدات الطبيه
والى ما هنالك انما ايضا
بالطوابق والغرف والسره والى ما هنالك هل
هناك مستشفيات لا تزال قادره على استيعاب
من هم في المستشفيات التي تخرج عن الخدمه
او لا
حتى الان توجد بعض المستشفيات الان هي قيد
العمل ولكن للاسف والسعه السريريه لكن لا
يمكن لها استيعاب كل هذا العدد خاصه ان
المستشفيات التي خرجت عن الخدمه هي من
المستشفيات الكبيره التي ليست تقدم خدمه
فقط
للمواطنين في داخل الولايات الخرطوم وانما
يتم التحويل لها نقول
من كل مناطق السودان المختلفه
فاذا المشكله الان
مشكله في
مشكله في شحا القوادر يعني اذا كانت
العاصمه التي تحول اليها كل الحالات من
الولايات
مستشفياتها منهاره وخارجه عن الخدمه بشكل
مستشفياتها الاساسيه فهذا سيمتد الى كل
الولايات والمناطق الاخرى بطبيعه الحال في
الايام المقبله لنشهد كارثه انسانيه طبيه
استشفائيه حقيقيه في عموم السودان
هنالك انهيار تام للنظام الصحي
بعض مستشفيات الولايات الان اصبحت خارج عن
الخدمه نسبه لعمليات التبادل وعدم الامان
فيها ونسبه
لشحن طوادر
انعدام لبعض المعينات الطبيه اللازمه
لعمليه التطبيق
لذلك
يصعب على على هذه الولايات اداره
المستشفياتها لانها تعتمد اساسا على
الامداد الذي ياتي من الخرطوم لذلك قدمتها
مناشدات للمجتمع الدولي وللمنظمات للتدخل
خاصه وان عدد مقدر من المنظمات لديه فروع
في تلك الولايات
سنعمل خلال
ما تبقى منهن التي لم يتم الالتزام بها
حتى الان
لتوصيل المعينات الطبيه
لادلاع المصابين وبعض الجثث
مفهوم معلش دقق لي بموضوع البرامج
العالميه والمنظمات الدوليه
ما بعرف يا ريت نركز بس على هذه النقطه كم
من الاشخاص بعد يعملون هناك فيها وما هي
قدرتها على العمل الان لانه بعضها اوقف
عماله تماما
انتم على تواصل معها هل انتم على التواصل
مع هذه البرامج نحن هنا تواصل معها ولكن
قدرتها على العمل تعتمد على فتح المسارات
الامنه
ذلك
الامر يعني
هذا التدخل يعتمد على مدى التزام الطرفيه
الصراع بالهدنه التي اعلنوها تمام منظمه
الصحه العالميه تقول الان انه الهجمات على
العاملين الصحيين والمرافق الصحيه وسيارات
الاسعاف في السودان اخذ في الازدياد هنا
اسالك هل يعني هل اي جهه من قبلكم في
نقابه الاطباء قادره على التواصل مع اي
طرف عسكري يعني اقصد في القوات المسلحه
يصعب يصعب التواصل يصعب التواصل معهم
ويصعب التواصل مع طرفيه الصراع لذلك نحن
طلبنا ان يتم التواصل عبر الامم المتحده
طيب طلبت من مين
طلبنا من طلبنا من مؤسسات الامم المتحده
موجوده في السودان خاطبناها عبر خطابات
رسميه بس هي غير قادره على التحرك والعمل
بكامل طاقاتها الان اليس كذلك
ولكنها لديها تواصل لدى المسؤولين عنها
تواصل مع
الطرفيه الصراط
القوات المسلحه المفروض عندها مستشفيات
ومؤسسات عسكريه
متخصصه طبيا هل هناك امكانيه لان يعني لان
تمدكم هذه المؤسسه العسكريه بما ينقصكم
الان
لها لا يتوقع انها
انه الوضع لا يسمح يعني باعتقادك طيب هل
يمكن ان نقول على الهواء ما هي ابرز
مطالبكم الان الاكثر الحاحا
المطالب الاكثر الحاحا هي الالتزام
بالخدمه والعمل على الوقف الدائم لاطلاق
النار واقصى هذه الحرب العاطفيه
كما نطالب بفتح مسارات امنه وتحديدها
وتامينها من قبل هذه القوات المتقاتله
والحفاظ على
معلش نستمع على صوت طبيعي قليلا تبقى معنا
دكتور
ابقى معنا دكتور
تفضل دكتور
نعم
معك تفضل يمكن ان تتابع الان اشير لك الى
انه منظمه الصحه العالميه تعبر عن القلق
الان ايضا ازاء تقارير عن ضربات على
المرافق الصحيه ونهبها واختطاف سيارات
الاسعاف
هل سمعت اي اخبار او معلومات مؤكده عن
اختطاف سيارات اسعاف بتفاصيل مؤكده عن
يعني عدد الناس الذين اختطفوا في داخلها
ما كانت حالاتهم ولماذا
حتى الان
ولكن تم الاعتداء على طبيه في هنالك عدد
من الكوادر الطبيه
استشهدوا
وهم في طريقهم الى الى العمل او في طريقهم
الى الى منازلهم او جزء
نتيجه لوقوع قذائف في المنازل وبالتالي
الان هو في توجد حاله التفلت عام
متوقع ازدياد حالات النهب سواء كان من
احدى القوتين المتقاتلين او من بعض
العصابات التي بدات تنشط في القدرات
الاخيره
تمام
تبقى معنا دكتور ينضم الينا الان مدير عام
مستشفى الخرطوم التعليمي دكتور حسن ساتي
اهلا بك معنا دكتور اريد ان اقف معك ايضا
على وضعكم انتم في المستشفى الان
عليكم السلام ورحمه الله وبركاته
ونتمنى ان شاء الله ان تقول هذه الامه
ويعود السودان امنا
[موسيقى]
الوقود الى داخل المستشفى لانه في منطقه
قريبه من الى القياده العامه من مناطيل
الله
اللطيف فيها فيها
يعني لا وقود الان في المستشفى
نعم نعم في المستشفى ولا يمكنكم التحدث مع
اي جهه كي تمدكم بالوقود ان كانت عسكريه
او غير عسكريه
بعض الاشخاص لكن الدخول الى الموسيقى صعب
يعني
طيب ماذا انتم فاعلون في هذه الحاله
الان
شد الاخوه
سمعنا ان هنالك هنا نتمنى ان تصبح هذه
الهدنه حقيقيه حتى يصبح الوصول والخروج من
المستشفى
دكتور ماذا انتم فاعلون الان بعد فشل
الهدنه يعني كيف تتصرفون في المستشفى
الطبيه
الان نحن الان
في بدايه الليل الحلقه العامه برضو صعبه
صعبه جدا
الحمد لله
نستطيع تقديم الخدمات للمرضى المستشفى
في احيان في احيان عم بسمعك بصعوبه
اتحملني بس هل صار في استهداف مباشر
للمستشفى او انه اصيب بالتبادل لاطلاق
النار
بعض القبائل داخل داخل الصوره المستشفى
وفي بعض المرافقين
يعني
داخل يعني منطقه الله يعني
داخل داخل سور
هل قتل وسيم احد جرى ذلك
اصابات يعني اصابات
كم اصابه بفعل بفعل الاشتباكات
من مرافقي المرضى
هل حاله المرضى الطبيه الان في خطر
الان الامور مستقله الحمدلله حاله المرضى
يعني
طبعا تعلم ان صعب
معارض المرضى تقديم الخدمات بدون وجود
كهرباء بالضبط
[موسيقى]
منتصف النهار الى استشاره اخرى الان
حافظنا على المرضى الذين لا يحتاجون ان
يكونوا مركبين
الان نقوم بالتعاون مع اسطوانه الاكسجين
مطالبكم الاكثر الحاحا الان يعني يمكن ان
يكون صوتا مسموعا ان شاء الله على الهواء
ان شاء الله اتمنى ان تتمكن من اصلاح داخل
الكهربائي هذا الطلب الاول الطلب الثاني
وجود وقود وتوصيله الى داخل المستشفى
واقولة
الخرطوم من برا المسجلات في السودان وهو
الان في هذه المنطقه الاوحد الذي يعمل
الان يعني لدينا ثلاثه مستشفيات قريبه
منها الان هي خارج
الخدمه تماما لا انتم المسلسل الوحيد الذي
يعمل الان
الان عاصمه ككل
لا لا هذه فيها داخل هذه المنطقه
المنطقه القريبه من القياده العامه
بقيه المناطق الاساسيه في الخرطوم
تحويل بعض المرضى الى مستشفى
تعمل حتى الان
هي مناط
بعيده من مناطق القتال المواجهات
والشيء الثالث والاخير
بتحويل بعض المرضى ونقلهم الى الى
مستشفيات خارج هذه المنطقه اذا انتم
تطالبون بما ممرات امنه انسانيه لنقل
المرضى من المستشفيات التي تحتاج الى
الوقود لتشغيل الاجهزه الطبيه اللازمه
اذا نداء من مستشفى الخرطوم التعليمي عبر
العربيه للاطراف المتقاتله يعني استحداث
ممرات انسانيه
طارئه وعاجله من اجل انقاذ تكون امنه
بطبيعه الحال من اجل انقاذ ارواح المرضى
ممن هم في المستشفى مستشفى الخرطوم
والمستشفيات الاخرى
وبعضها قد خرج عن العمل من اجل انقاذ
ارواح هؤلاء قبل فوات الاوان
طيب انتم بالتالي لم ليس بامكانكم ان
تستقبلوا بعد الان
اي مصابين او مرضى اليس كذلك
[موسيقى]
المصابين
المقدمه الخدمات الاوليه ايقاف النزيف
والمعاليات الاوليه
موجود
خدمه صعب جدا كانت طبيعه اصابتها هؤلاء
غالبا يعني
بعض
الاصابات من القنابل التي تتطايف
اصابته وما الذي تسمعونه من هؤلاء
المصابين الذين ياتون اليكم عن وقت
اصاباتهم مكان اصاباتهم الجهه التي يمكن
ان تكون قد استهدفتهم
هي المنطقه هذه منطقه مواجهات يعني
المستشفي قاع في منطقه
بها مواجهات منطقه مواجهات وبالتالي انتم
غير قادرين على الخروج اطلاقنا
يعني يمكن القوي لكن بصعوبه يعني المستشفى
تنام في داخلها ولا تستطيع الخروج الان
يعني
وكيف تؤمنون احتياجاتكم اليوميه
[موسيقى]
من المواد الغذائيه
يعني نخرج ونتكلم عن القوات الموجوده انه
هذا مستشفى وهذا
خاصه
تمام منظمه الصحه العالميه دكتور الان
تعبر عن القلق اذا تقارير عن ضربات على
المرافق الصحيه وعنهبه واختطاف سيارات
الاسعاف كما نذكر ولكن هناك جديد ايضا
الهجمات على العاملين والمنشات الصحيه
انتهاك صارخ للقانون الدولي ويجب على
اطراف النزاع ضمان الوصول الامن للمرضى
والعاملين الى المستشفيات يعني جزء مما
كنا نتحدث عنه معك وجزء من نداءك عبر قناه
العربيه منظمه الصحه العربيه العالميه اذا
تحدثت عن 16 مستشفى في الخرطوم وولايات
اخرى لا تقدم خدماتها اضافه الى 16 اخرى
على وشك الخروج عن الخدمه هل يمكن ان تؤكد
لنا مثل هذه المعلومات دكتور ساتي
يعني ولو تقديريا يعني هل هذا معقول
الكلام
طبعا مستشفى في الخرطوم وولايات اخرى
حتى الان يعني
عن الجهات الاخرى
تمام انا اذكر وجودك معنا شكرا جزيلا على
وقتك رغم كل ما تمرون به نامل ان تمر هذه
الساعات عليكم يعني
وانتم يعني صابرون عليها شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور ساتي حسن ساتي مدير عام مستشفى
الخرطوم التعليمي
جبهه حرب جديده فتحت افواه السلاح في
السودان طرف الحرب عسكريان كلاهما تمرس في
ميادين القتال بدرفورد اما وصفه الصداع
فمكوناتها تقتصر على وجود قوتين مسلحتين
داخل الدوله الواحده
مصير البلاد حاليا بات على راحتي من كان
من المفترض حمايته والقادم لا ينظر الا
بصيف حار سيثقل كاهل السودانيين مجددا بعد
ان عاشوا حروبا وانقلابات عده جلبت
الويلات لهم
تاريخيا المره الاخيره التي تقاتل فيها
قائد عسكري ونائبه شرقي افريقيا كان في
جنوب السودان وقتل حينها حوالي 400 الف
شخص اما صراع اليوم فيزعزع استقرار جارتها
الشماليه وما يدور حاليا فيه قد ينتهي فقط
بفوز احدهم في المعركه مع عدم استبعاد حرب
اهليه طويله الامد قد تجر جيرانها وفق
صحيفه
على مدى السنوات الماضيه تشارك البرهان
واحمدت معارك عده معا يد واحده وقوه
مشتركه
ففي عام 2021 اكد احمدتي لصحيفه في ان
قوات الدعم السريع تدعم القوات المسلحه
السودانيه فيما اخبر البرهان الصحيفه
الغربيه انه بمجرد اكمال الانتقال الى
الديمقراطيه سيعود القاده الى التكنات
وسيتم اجراء تصويت في عام 2023
وعود تبخرت مع اطلاق رصاصه الاولى منذ
اربعه ايام من العاصمه الخرطوم ليدخل
السودان ازمه خطيره ربما يمكن ان تحسم
صلحا او تتوسع وتاكل ما تبقى من البلاد
اياد حمود العربيه
نعود الى دكتور علي بشير نائب رئيس اللجنه
التمهيديه لنقابه الاطباء في السودان اهلا
بك معنا مجددا دكتور كنا نسال قبل قليل عن
اختطاف سيارات الاسعاف وفقا لما تحدثت عنه
منظمه الصحه العالميه التي عبرت عن القلق
اذا هذه التقارير هل لديك ما تؤكده لنا في
هذا المجال
مرحب بكم للمره الثانيه حتى الان لا تاكيد
ان هذا الخبر نعم
ليس لديكم تاكيدات عن هذا الخبر 16 مستشفى
في الخرطوم لكنه غير مستبعد منظمه الصحه
تقول ايضا انه 16 مستشفى في الخرطوم
وولايه اخرى لا تقدم خدماتها الان اضافه
الى
سته عشره او سته عشره اخرى على وشك الخروج
من الخدمه هل هذاك هذا معقول بالنسبه
اليكم حتى لو لم يكن هناك احصاء الدقيقه
حتى الساعه
نعم هذه المعلومات صحيحه وبلغ العدد
بمستشفى صبير خروجها عن عن العمل 17
مستشعر كما الذي تبقى يعمل كما الذي تبقى
من المستشفيات التي تعمل اذا اذا قمنا
بحساب سريع تقديري
حتى الان يعني هذه المستشفيات الكبيره
يعني ما تبقى هو مجرد مستشفيات ليست
تعليميه او متخصصه
يعني عمليا لا عمليا يعني لا مستشفيات او
نحن على وشك ان نكون امام واقع انه لا
مستشفيات تعمل على الاطلاق في الخرطوم على
الاقل لذلك عندما قلت لك نحن الان مهددون
بانهيار الكامل
للنظام الصحه
الان على على ان ان نعيد هذه المستشفيات
الى الخدمه وان ندعم المستشفيات التي هي
على وشك الخروج عن الخدمه
بالاضافه الى كيف تفعلون ذلك
بالتنسيق يعني مع عدد من المنظمات
والكوادر الطبيه الاخرى غير الاطباء الان
نحن الاطباء على اتم الاستعداد عملنا عدد
من الاديان في الاحياء
للتعامل يعني مع الحالات
الحالات الاصابه نعم
القصف العشوائي او التبادل الذي يمكن ان
يتم خاصه وانه التبادل الان يتم في في كل
يعني مدن العاصمه وفي معظم المدن
السودانيه
ما هذا واضح جدا شكرا جزيلا
حتى يتجنب الكوادر الطبيه والمصابين
المرور بالطرق الرئيسيه على الاقل يعني ان
يكون هناك ممرات امنه لسيارات الاسعاف كما
قلنا قبل قليل شكرا جزيلا لك اعذرني على
المقاطعه دكتور علي بشير يجب ان نكتفي
بهذا القدر معك نائب رئيس اللجنه
التمهيديه لنقابه الاطباء في السودان على
ان يكون الصوت قد وصل نتابع ما لدينا في
هذه الساعه الاخباريه المتواصله لتغطيه
احداث التطورات في السودان او التطورات
الاحداث هناك بالاحرى احتفالات جنود من
الجيش السوداني عقب استعاده السيطره على
مطار مراوين نتابعها
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ان بلاده ستكثف الاتصالات مع الاطراف
السودانيه المتنازعه من اجل استئناف
الحوار السلمي لتسويه الوضع بينهما وجدد
شكر التاكيد ايضا على ضروره ان يمتنع جميع
اصحاب المصلحه والنفوذ الاجانب عن تصعيد
الوضع في السودان معبرا عن امله في التوصل
الى حل قريب بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
كشفت مصادر خاصه للعربيه عن تحركات مصريه
اقليميه تشمل دخول مراقبين دوليين للوصول
الى وقف لاطلاق النار خلال عيد الفطر فتح
ممرات امنه بين مصر والسودان لمده 48 ساعه
للسماح بنقل المصابين ودخول المساعدات
الانسانيه بالاضافه الى تخصيص لجنه امميه
دوليه
لتسهيل دخولها من اجل الاشراف على كافه
الاسرى من الجانبين وتسهيل مهام بعثات
الامم المتحده وبرامج الغذاء العالميه من
خلال تعيين قوه خاصه لتامين مهامهم داخل
الاراضي السودانيه واوضحت المصادر ان هذه
المناقشات تدور حول توقيت وقف اطلاق النار
والانسحاب الى خطوط يتم الاتفاق عليها
في الاثناء اوضح المتحدث والاقليمي باسم
الخارجيه المصريه سامويلرج انا واشنطن
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه اذا صرح بان
واشنطن على اتصال مستمر مع دول المجاوره
والدول التي لديها تاثير على السودان
لمحاوله ايجاد حل لهذه الازمه الحاليه
الذين مناقشات واسيه جدا مع كل الاطراف في
المنطقه وخرج من المنطقه ولكن ابرز منها
بدون شك ما سمعنا من البيام وستخراجيه حول
الاتصال بين وزير بلينكن والنظرائه
السعودي والاماراتي بدون شك نحن في تواصل
يومي مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه مع
الامارات العربيه المتحده بدون شك نحن في
تواصل مع مصر والدول الاخرى المجاوره اذا
نحن في تواصل مع كلا ليس من الممكن
الى ذاتها على السودانيين من الازمه كنا
في المجتمع الدولي نتكلم بصوت واحد معقول
الاطراف السودانيه
من الخرطوم عبر الهاتف شريف محمد عثمان
الامينه السياسي لحزب المؤتمر السوداني
والمتحدث باسم قوه الحريه وتغيير اهلا بك
معنا استاذ شريف في هذه الساعه ايضا من
العربيه هل ما تحدثنا عنه للتو عن بعض
الجهود المصريه والاقليميه من اجل يعني
التوصل الى وقف الاطلاق النار يمكن
باعتقادك ان يتم الاتفاق عليه في الساعات
المقبله رغم فشل الهدنه حتى الان
الساعات القادمه والضغط عليهم لاستمرار
الهدنه لوقت اطول بقليل وايضا مطلوبا
البحث عمليات لمتابعه هذه الغنه والالزام
الاطراف الالتزام بها هذا
الدول الرباعيه كل الدول الداعمه
لعمليه التحول المدني للسودان في اطار
الوقفه الحرب ولكن هل فكره دخول مراقبين
دوليين فكره جيده باعتقادك ويمكن ان تكون
ناجعه ومؤقته
[موسيقى]
مراقبه محليه مع الاليه ثلاثيه هناك
الوصول مراقبين دوليا
المطارات على اللغه حتى هذا الوقت جميعها
مغلقه لا توجد رحلات طيران
لدخول السودان لكن علينا مناقشه اليه
متوافق حوله
ا على
الاوضاع الكارثيه الاوضاع الانسانيه
الفارسيه صحي في السودان السودان الاطار
الصحي فيه اصلا يعاني من
متقا فكره طويله تحدثنا كثيرا في هذه
الساعه استاذ شريف عن هذا الموضوع اذا
سمحت لي استفيد من وجودك معنا لاسالك بعض
الاسئله الاخرى
بموضوع يعني المراقبه وفتح الممرات مع دول
اخرى مثل مصر يعني كل بنود هذا الاتفاق
اللي عم تشتغل عليه مصر ودول اقليميه اخرى
ما الذي سيجعله ينجح باعتقادك مدام فشلت
يعني الهدنه في ساعتها الاولى اليوم
اطراف الكلام
هي ناقصه هذا الامر وناقشه
اليه سبيل تشكيل عاليه لمراقبه رخصه اطلاق
النار اعتقد انه ستطور هذه العليه خلال
اليومين القادمين
حضراتكم يعني كنتم تتفقون على امور معينه
متعلقه بالاتفاق الاطاري ومن ثم حصل ما
حصل
الذي داره فيهم لم يكن حول
نقاش هو
منع خطابات الحرب وخطابات الكارهين
الكراهيه
انتم وصلتم الى ما وصلتم اليه من اتفاقات
ومن ثم حصل ما حصل اذا التطورات الحرب
هذين اليومين تطورات الحرب فرضت ظروفا
جديده وربما شروطا جديده هل ستعودون الى
النقاش السياسي عندما تسكت اصوات المدافع
والرشاشات بنفس الشروط والمطالب القديمه
ام انه يجب ادخال تعديلات جوهريه على ما
تم الاتفاق عليه
اولا اي حرف في تاريخ في تاريخ الدنيا
تنتهي بحل سياسي وباتفاق سياسي
بدل ان نخسر ملايين الارواح والنزوح
وتدمير للبنيه التحتيه ومن ثم نعطي الخيار
الحل السياسي وخيار مطروحه الان وهو اهم
الان اكثر من من عليه في الوقت الذي نبدا
فيه النقاش على كل
طرفاضعته نحن ملتزمين بشكل باين بان يكون
لدينا جيش واحد وطني ومهني وظن الله منذ
اوقات عديده نقول ان الازمه بين هذه
المكونين ستوري هذه البلاد موجوده الهالات
على الجميع ان يلتزم ببناء جيش وطني واحد
ومهني وهذا ما سنظل ملتزمين لا حوله لدينا
متعلقه بمشروع التحول المدني الديمقراطي
ستضم قاعدين مطروحه وعلى الجانبين الدعم
السريع
القوات المسلحه ان يطرح البضائع المتباين
حولها والقضايا الثلاثيه ومن ثم عبر
النظام سنصل لصيغه من التوافق بين
الجانبين
يعني بمده الدمج بطبيعه الدمج ومده الدمج
والفتره الانتقاليه يعني بشكل عام بالتالي
وتسريح الضباط والى ما هنالك يعني انتم ما
الدور الذي يمكن ان يكون مانوطا بكم في
صراع عسكري عسكري بين قوتين كبيرتين
كل هذه القضايا بسيطه ويمكن معالجتها
مقارنه مع كلفه الحرب كلفه الحرب لا
توازيها اي اي كلفه في نهايه المطاف
سينتهي هذا الامر بنفس الترتيبات ترتيبيات
ترتيبات الدمج والتسريح وعمليه الاصلاح
هذه القضايا هي قضايا مصلحه خذنا المسلحه
وحكومه السودان حرب مع اطراف العمليه
سلميه الموجودون منذ عام 2003 وانتهت
باتفاق سلام الذي فيه ترتيبات حول
الترتيبات السودانيه الحرب منذ عام 83
السلامه الشامل والذي انتهت بانفصال جنوب
السودان في 2005 عليه يجب ان ننهي هذه
الحرب الاليه المعتمده لانهاء اي حرف لا
توجد حرف في بخاسره ومهزوم الخاسره الوحيد
في هذه الحرب هو السودان والسودان البنيه
التحتيه للاغتصاب قتل تشريب نزوح هذه
النتائج الطبيعيه لاي انا لدي ما اتابع
فيه معك في هذه النقطه اذا تفضلت بالبقاء
معنا ولكن نشير لو سمحت لي استاذ شريف الى
انهاء وزاره الداخليه السودانيه انتداب
جميع ضباط الشرطه بقوات الدعم السريع في
ظل الاحداث التي تشهدها البلاد نتابع معكم
هذه الصوره لرئيس دائره التدريب بالدعم
السريع اللواء ركن محمد احمد عباس الذي
سلم نفسه لسلاح الاشاره وانضم للجيش حيث
كان منتدبا
نعود اليك استاذ شريف في النقطه التي كنت
تتحدث عنها قبل قليل
فيما يتعلق بقوات الدعم السريع والعلاقه
بينها وبين الجيش لماذا لم نسمع حتى الان
في من كل المداخله يعني اغلب مداخلات ضيوف
على الهواء في مختلف وسائل الاعلام
موقفا حاسما واضحا مما يجري وان هناك وكان
هناك تخوف مما يمكن ممن يمكن ان ينتصر على
الاخر وبالتالي يحسب من يظهر على الهواء
الف حساب لمالات الامور لماذا ليس هناك
موقف موحد حاسم قاطع مع القوات المسلحه
السودانيه مثلا كمؤسسه وطنيه جامعه لكل
السودانيين مقابل قوات الدعم السريع او
لمن يشاء ان يقف مع قوات الدعم السريع
يعني فليفعل ولكن هناك محاوله لامساك
العصا من المنتصف هل يمكن ان تفسر لنا ذلك
بالعكس نحن دائما ملحدين لخيار
[موسيقى]
انا اقول بكل وضوح نحن منحازين لخيار
الخيار لخيارات الشعب المسلحه هي مواد
الشعب المسلحه وهذا وهذا هو اسمها الدعم
السريع حسب ترتيبات التي صنعتها الدعم
السريع خلال الفكره الماضيه تم اجازتها
لكن المحاوله
السودان عبر الخطاف على
من يدعمون القوات المسلحه وهذا الاصتصاص
بدعم الدعم السريع الاتفاق في مسجد
السودان الصحيح ان تصطفل جوه المدنيه
وتضغط هذه الحرف ليس فيها مصلحه
للشعب السوداني والشعب السوداني لم لم هذه
الحرب وتاريخ السودان طويل
اقصد من اي حرب
خاضتها
الحركات المسلحه ضد القوات المسلحه
بدون شك يعني مهما طال الزمن شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المشاركه استاذ شريف محمد
عثمان الامين سياسي لحزب المؤتمر السوداني
والمتحدث باسم قوى الحريه والتغيير اظن
على المقاطعه ولكن انتهى وقت هذه الساعه
الا ان التغطيه مستمره بعد قليل مع
الزميله ميسون نواهد تتابع واياكم فارجو
ان تتفضلوا بالبقاء معها ومعنا الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات